Here's everything I eat in a day
as someone that loves to cook,
is 34 weeks pregnant,
but is having a really lazy cooking day.
Had to start my day off with a cup of robus tea
and some milk.
I also hate the taste of water, so today
I opted for some iced water with some apple juice
just to stay hydrated
and then moved on to making my breakfast.
I've been into savoury and sweet breakfast,
so I decided on caramelized soy mushrooms
on one side of the toast and tomato on the other.
I also had some of my kids leftover oatmeal
with some peach vanilla puree and banana.
And I always need a lunch pick me up,
so I had a culture pop and an iced lavender honey tea.
Since we're sticking to quick and easy meals,
I did a baked potato
with some quick pickled sumoc onions,
a kimchi tartar sauce,
and honey mustard salmon.
While the potato was baking,
I made my sides and marinated my salmon.
And 15 minutes before the potato was done roasting,
I popped the salmon in,
let that roast,
and then assembled it all with butter,
the salmon, tartar sauce,
dill, and the pickled onions.
You guys, this was divine.
Love a little afternoon pick me up.
So I had this coconut
mango smoothie that I have almost every single day
and this sumo citrus.
They've been one of my pregnancy cravings
and I need to have one at Least every day
dinner time rolled around,
I wanted something comforting.
I've been thinking about making gnocchi soup
for so long,
so that's what I did today.
I chopped up some carrots,
celery, and onion.
Let that sweat down with some sun dried tomato oil
before adding some Calabrian chili tomato paste,
adding my shredded chicken.
In the meantime,
my husband was making us an arugula Parmesan salad.
Also needed to use up some kale,
so I tossed it in there as well
before adding my cauliflower
gnocchi and dressing the salad.
Plated up my dinner,
added some lemon and Parmesan cheese on top.
I was starving at this point,
so I couldn't wait.
And I burnt my mouth,
but it was definitely worth it.